Jennifer Aniston reunites with
ex-husband Justin Thoreau in New York
City I guess it keeps us on our toes huh
yeah the rare sighting comes as the
former spouses met up for dinner with
friends Jason Bateman and his wife
Amanda Anka both exes kept their looks
low-key Jen rocking a long black coat
while Justin Sports dark jeans a
button-up and black boots
gently tells me just in the life of the
party at your guys's party is that true
he actually is right he is the life of
the people you don't want to throw it
without him and get this the actress
left the restaurant with a single red
rose in hand
I'll take it as for what it means
Jen have history
the pair began dating in 2011 and
married in 2015.
I got a good one I got a sweet kind man
yeah yeah fast forward to 2018 and Jen
and Justin split but remained on good
terms
both openly supporting each other on
social media and even talking about the
possibility of working together again
well I'd love to see Justin's throw pop
on over there to the morning show well
I'll listen if there's something they
want to send me some pages
I was thinking you and I how do we get
together and just sort of work on some
ideas
yeah Justin's down for a part in Jen's
Apple TV plus series The Morning Show
she's doing a totally different show
she's in Los Angeles obviously shooting
her show and bopping around uh there
yeah we would check in and you know I
think we're both having fabulous
experiences it's that perfect balance of
support last year he opened up to
Esquire about his relationship with his
ex-wife
telling the mag I'm sincere when I say
that I cherish our friendship we cannot
be together and still bring each other
joy and friendship Justin added that Jen
quote makes me laugh very very hard it's
a good thing it would be a loss if we
weren't in contact for me personally and
I'd like to think the same for her
so for now seems the pair is just
friends
but things are clearly Rosy between them
foreign